vor allem kinder und jugendliche leben
ja zunehmend in diesen digitalen welten
häufig sind die folge normal
konkurrenzdruck mobbing erst störungen
depressionen bis hin auch zum suizid und
wir wollen darüber sprechen mit der
staatsministerin für digitalisierung im
kanzleramt dorothee bär von der csu
sowie auch schauspielerin anne-sophie
briest die durch den film endstation
baby strich bekannt geworden ist guten
morgen an sie beide
guten morgen guten morgen fangen wir an
mit anna sophie marie ist ihre tochter
ist ja influenza in scheiben und hannah
sehr erfolgreich übrigens wie stehen sie
denn zu dem job ihrer tochter
naja der job meiner tochter war ja in
erster linie bis eben noch schülerin sie
hat er gerade das abitur gemacht und ist
ja in dem sinne keine influenza sondern
sie ist sängerin und schauspielerin und
nutzt instagram sozusagen um dort ihr
publikum zu erreichen ich glaube da gibt
es dann auch unter umständen diese
unterschiede dass man eben diese medien
nutzt um
inhalte zu transportieren oder eben
andere die dieses medium als
geschäftsmodell benutzen und einfach nur
inhalte herstellen um damit geld zu
verdienen das ist glaube ich noch mal
ein unterschied denn noch ist es so wir
sehen hier auch gerade die bilder zeigt
sie sich sehr freizügig ist das nicht
ihrer meinung nach auch gefährlich sie
es gerade volljährig geworden macht dass
er aber auch schon seit vielen jahren
also das freizügige gilt es zu
definieren das definieren sie jetzt als
sehr freizügig wenn ich durch das
instagram meiner tochter coco habe ich
da kein problem mit ich glaube das ist
auch immer eine frage des
anlasses wie man sich kleidet also so
geht man natürlich wieder in den
gerichtssaal noch in die schule zum
beispiel würde ich jetzt mal sagen aber
dass man sich so anzieht ist es glaube
ich jedem selbst überlassen wie sich
anzieht oder ob es im bikini am strand
schild also noch einmal kein bedeckung
verbot ich kann mich jetzt auch nicht
erinnern dass es in duncan wahlprogramm
hoffentlich drin war also ich empfinde
das jetzt nicht so und über jungs wird
ja auch nicht gesprochen die ihre hose
unter dem hintern tragen oder sich
teilweise oberkörper frei im internet
bewegen also ich sehe kein problem wenn
sie ein problem daran vorbei
ich glaube der ganz grosse und steht ist
halt immer dass wir schauen müssen wie
wir uns um unsere kinder und
jugendlichen kümmern und was mit über 18
jährigen ist also ich setze da schon
sehr stark auch auf selbstbestimmung
gerade bei erwachsenen aber bei kindern
und jugendlichen muss man natürlich
genau hinschauen und die vorwürfe jetzt
auch von frances augen die sind
natürlich wirklich dramatisch
substanziell vor allem wenn es in dem
wissen geschieht das bewusst kinder
geschädigt werden um profi zu mehren
dann ist es etwas was uns erstens mal
natürlich nicht kalt lässt und auf der
anderen seite ja auch etwas was wir auch
regulatorisch auf europäischer ebene
schon angehen weil wir ja auch mit dem
titel des services act und dem titel
market sector auch maßnahmen ergreifen
werden um auch dieses zeitalter der
exzesse wir haben ja teilweise noch
wildwest dass wir geben auch einhalt
gebieten wer wie gefährlich sind denn
ihrer meinung nach sozialer netzwerke
naja es ist wie beim messer jahr licht
und schatten also schwierig mir ein brot
oder erstelle ich jemanden und bei
sozialen netzwerken gibt es eben viele
vorteile es gibt selbsthilfegruppen ist
es gibt die möglichkeit anonym auch in
staaten die wirklich ansonsten keine
möglichkeit haben gegen ihre china
aufzubegehren dass sich zu äußern auch
aus dem untergrund heraus das ist ganz
ganz wichtig für ganz viele staaten die
nicht das glück haben so wie wir in
einer demokratie leben zu dürfen und
natürlich gibt es diese ganzen
schattenseiten und da sind wir schon in
der verantwortung genau hinzuschauen ich
wiederhole noch mal ganz besonders bei
kindern und bei jugendlichen das sich
eben ganz bestimmte exzesse die da sind
dass eben
sich mädchen mit ihrem körper nicht wohl
fühlen das ist vielleicht noch mal die
abgemilderter form aber dass man
tatsächlich dann auch in die magersucht
abrutscht oder selbstmordgedanken pflegt
oder mit seinem eigenen leben nicht mehr
überein stimmt es sind natürlich dann
auch exzesse die ganz genau angeschaut
werden müssen und wo auch in großen
plattformen in einem europäischen
zusammenschluss einhalt geboten werden
muss frau berichten von sony center
schmunzelte als frau bär sprache sehen
sie es nicht so dramatisch
ich habe geschwitzt bei frau bär sprach
nein weil ich ihre meinung bin da bin
ich ganz bei ihr es gibt immer die zwei
seiten der medaille
natürlich kann man sich ja wie gesagt
man kann es ist eine frage der dosis
sozusagen bei allem ja man kann in der
marca so zum beispiel abrutschen man
kann sich aber auch hilfe im internet
suchen es kommt darauf an wie man dieses
medium nutzt und wie bei allen dingen
ist es eine frage der dosis man sollte
damit verantwortungsvoll umgehen und da
ist es einfach ganz wichtig dass kinder
und jugendliche früh begleitet werden
was ich zum beispiel bei meiner tochter
gemacht habe dass kinder und jugendliche
wissen haben zu dem thema und dass
eltern vor allem auch verantwortung
übernehmen aber wie ist ihre tochter
tritt dort ja auch als vorbild auch für
andere kinder die vielleicht nicht so
gut aussehen wie sie und setzt diesen
kindern dann auch natürlich sich an
konkurrenzdruck aus
ja dann ist es halt so dass er eltern
immer noch dafür verantwortlich sind
wenn sie wenn die kinder social media
nutzen das muss er von den eltern
betreut werden der account und da muss
man fair ja nicht folgen also das ist ja
eine freiwilligkeit und wenn sieben mit
versprechen würden dann würden sie
feststellen dass die natürlich genauso
wie andere mädchen ihre unsicherheiten
hat aus ihrer haut ist ob es weiß ich
was ist und darüber spricht sie auch
ganz viel und besonders zu jungen
menschen zb in ihrem podcast das finde
ich ganz wichtig dass man sich auch nur
auch äußert und das ist dann die
vorbildfunktion die sie da erfüllen kann
indem man
sozusagen ins gespräch geht mit seinen
fans oder menschen die einem folgen wir
helfen sie dann auch als mutter wenn da
mal negative kommentare reinkommen was
ja durchaus passiert
ja die negativen kommentare kommen gar
nicht so im internet erstaunlicherweise
sondern man wird auch gerne von
erwachsenen angesprochen
zudem wie man gerade aussieht was man
hat in welchem verfassungs zustand man
gerade ist oder was auch immer da müssen
man muss man vielleicht auch im echten
leben erstmal dahin kommen dass man ein
bisschen vorsichtiger mit seinen
kommentaren umgeht und dann schaffen wir
es vielleicht auch kinder und
jugendliche
sich nicht den den ganzen erwachsenen
die
über politiker über menschen die in der
öffentlichkeit stehen oder andere
menschen ihren müll ausschütten einfach
da erstmal im echten leben vorbild sind
und da geht es glaube ich erst mal los
und dann werden wir vielleicht auch
dahin kommen dass wir verantwortungsvoll
jugendliche im internet haben die
einfach nachdenken bevor sie was sagen
oder schreiben probier bei den vorwürfen
von francis oben geht es nicht nur
morgen sondern auch um hasse sie sagt
konkrete dass facebook extra menschen
sozusagen auf weil die meisten klicks
gibt wenn dort wütende kommentare
abgegeben werden man kann aber auch
nichts dagegen tun weil das dann zensur
sei heißt es auf der anderen seite wie
kommt man raus aus diesem dilemma
ich glaube schon dass wir eine ganz
große chance haben europäische aus
diesem dilemma herauszukommen ich habe
den dsl ndm angesprochen da gibt es ja
auch und transparenzpflichten da geht es
um das offenlegen von algorithmen zum
einen gegenüber den wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern dass wir wirklich
mal reinkommen dass wir transparent
sehen wie diese algorithmen
funktionieren mindestens mal für die
wissenschaft aber natürlich auch
gegenüber der kommission die dann auch
die möglichkeit hat wenn genau das was
sie jetzt ansprechen dass da eine
spirale des hasses unterstützt wird das
desinformation vielleicht unterstützt
wird oder auch nur um gefährdungen
unterstützt wird durch algorithmen das
dem ganzen dann nicht nur einhalt
geboten werden kann sondern dass es dann
auch zu strafen kommen kann gegenüber
diesen plattformen
dankeschön ein solches gespräch
[Musik]